you win best t-shirt and background
combo of the day
i will say thank you and i wish you were
handing out a prize
um
being jumping into uh first of all um a
bunch of questions for you guys um uh
rita i know you haven't acted as much as
jack but i'm still gonna ask this
question for both of you if someone has
actually never seen
anything you've acted in before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why well
i had to go first because obviously
jack's
books are deeper than mine in this
department but i'd like to consider
myself a
a very serious actress in the sense of
picking the right characters for me um
i love to be able to have the
opportunity to
curate what i'd like to do in this field
and um
i'm very grateful for that you know i i
think
for me i'd love them to to really start
with my music videos because i think
with my music videos you get a sense of
my presence first on camera and also my
communication with others and
you know it was also a world that i
created which i'm really proud of so
it's it's it's a mixture of creative
control and inspiration and presence so
i'll start with that so when you work on
your music videos do you do you
collaborate with the directors and like
kind of co-direct in a way
well i kind of have the idea of
in my mind and then
whoever i pick to help me
direct it really just brings that to
life and
adds elements that i wouldn't
necessarily think of because i'm very
open to collaborating you know i think
that's such an important part of being
creative
um
and i think that's why
i'm here today to be able to collaborate
with jack black and do things that i
never really thought i could do so this
is a huge achievement for me and
something that i'd love to continue
doing
yeah
i agree with you the key is
collaboration and when you have that
kind of relationship with the director
that's the kind of thing that i'm the
most proud of too like probably
my proudest moment in the industry is
not the biggest hit
but tenacious d in the pick of destiny
because it's the only movie that i was
in that i wrote
and that you know i worked so closely
with the director and and it was like a
collaboration through and through
producing and you know
and
yeah it's just a great experience
so i'd want people to pick a destiny
even though i'm really just clowning
around super duper hard it's uh it's
also my baby
uh rita this is your first time uh
voicing a character like this on a
series like this
what surprised you about making an
animated series and voicing a character
that perhaps you weren't expecting going
in
you know i think
i thought i was gonna have to repeat
myself endlessly you know i thought it
was like oh let's do this again or let's
do this part again but there's no time
and i think that's why i love doing tv
animation honestly there's so many
episodes so much to get done that you're
really going in once a week or once
every couple weeks and
you're just going through the episodes
you know so it's always something
exciting you're seeing like new
characters obviously
um we're not always in the same room so
there's a lot of experimenting and i
love getting like in with my project so
i was really into sort of like getting
involved figuring out who this character
is because i'm up against iconic
characters you know what i'm saying
you've got two people that we um
characters animations poem
and msp and you know you've got these
characters that have existed for a long
time
so how am i going to stand amongst these
legends ledges is what i'd like to say
in the uk ledge
um
but i i think wandering blade herself
has really sustained the test of
time with her
wicked powerful ways in in a really
strong woman way i think i hope i've
answered your question
100
jack if i'm not mistaken this is your
first time voicing poe since kung fu
panda 3.
um
and so what was it and i know they've
done some other animated things what was
it about this story and and what was it
about you know why you wanted to come
back now um what what drew you back in
well i got the call from netflix
and they were saying we know you've only
done the movies but would you be
interested in uh
in reprising your role in a series
uh
and they told me the idea of it and it
just sounded intriguing because
it was
higher stakes and more of a global story
than the original movies that just took
place in china this took place all over
the world
with different cultures and different
characters and
and rita ora's character which is this
strong woman character who
kicks ass but also has
uh secrets and vulnerabilities and
and it just seemed like uh
an awesome new adventure and it honestly
just seemed like a lot of fun
and i liked peter the director and his
vision for where it would go over the
course course of the series
so it was a no-brainer really uh the
fourth episode has poe really obsessed
with a comic book and really for you
know um that's a big part of the story
uh is and and how the comic book plays
into the series um so it made me think
for both of you what was something when
you were growing up that you were really
obsessed with or even now something that
you're really obsessed with the way poe
is
with the comic
uh i was obsessed with comics actually
too i was really
deep into uh frank miller's like the
dark knight and his run that he did with
uh um uh what's the blind uh guy in the
red suit oh daredevil daredevil
um
and alan moore you know uh the watchman
uh
that's yeah i mean what do you or how
about you i loved i loved comic books
but
i loved when i was growing up i was into
kids books i was
like cat in the hat and
the caterpillar and all these really
interesting
books there's this one book
about a lighthouse that i'll never
forget
and i think it's called the lighthouse
and it was
and i always used to read it
and and i'm going to try and find it but
it's it's just those sort of like books
that have those same pictures that i
think were really interesting for me
anyway i i loved that things like that i
actually just put in an auction for the
first edition of dr zeus cat in the hat
oh man
i know i don't think i'm gonna get it
though
some of his paintings he he also has
like fine artwork paintings that go for
for top dollar now
i know i mean i just saw i like
collecting books like additional you
know first edition book so that that was
something i i enjoyed anyway yeah my
favorite was the birthday bird
it's a kind of a lesser known dr seuss
book
yeah
every every day even when it wasn't my
birthday
one of the things um about the voice
recording process that i think must be
interesting is when you have to record
all like the efforts when you're making
those weird sounds when you're going up
a hill or down or you have to react to
something what is it like what was it
like for both of you guys in the
recording booth when you have to not do
the dialogue but all those other sound
effects well it's in a way that's like
the
the most effort goes into those and i
always say can we save those for the
very end because i'm gonna i'm gonna
blast my throat out on those
and so we do all my dialogue stuff and
the emotional stuff and then when it
comes to that stuff
yeah i go i go balls to the walls okay i
go i go a thousand percent i only have
one gear so if i'm diving off a cliff
and like
blasting through a wall i'm really gonna
make those noises
and i'm gonna work up a sweat
uh peter our director made fun of me
because
it's cardio
yeah
hopefully there'll be some behind the
scenes so you see i'm not joking i'm
actually
i'm i'm you know it's life or death in
that recording studio i'm the same you
know i think you know you're doing
animation on you know our characters
jumping off cliffs running like off
literal mountains and boats and it's
insane so you can't just stand still
like we really are running up and down
in these studio rooms
um but yeah i don't really enjoy
those moments but i do like being able
to let loose i use it as therapy
you got a dress to move too you can't be
wearing any jewelry or anything when you
bring when you
you can't have any jingly jangles
you got to be really just like sweats
t-shirt
kick off the
shoes because uh it's gonna get real
real physical
on that note i need to stop i'm just
gonna say i hope the series is a huge
hit for you guys and thank you so much
for giving me your time appreciate you
thank you so much
you